Добрий день шановні колеги Щиро вітаємо
вас на засідання секції професійна
освіта результати Поточний стан і
перспективи наша секція проводиться в
рамках щорічної всеукраїнської серпневої
конференції події які Сьогодні
відбуваються в Україні вони перед нами
ставлять нові виклики але найголовнішим
нашим завданням є організація освітнього
процесу я забезпечення права здобуття
освіти в тому числі професійної освіти
нашими громадянами Ми сьогодні прагнемо
презентувати кращий досвід роботи наших
колег роботи закладів професійної освіти
поділитися з тим які викликами маємо на
сьогодні і як ми з ними намагаємося
впорати Дозвольте мені запросити до
вітального слова заступника міністра
освіти і науки України пана Олександра
костюченка
дякую доброго дня шановні колеги всіх
радий вітати на цьогорічній конференції
стіни прості часи для країни попри
масштабних повернення Російської
Федерації
дуже радий всіх бачити що ми зібралися
Що ми будемо
опрацьовувати і обговорювати ті проблеми
не питання які постають перед сферою
професійного технічної освіти разом
будемо намагатися шукати в них виходити
тощо
попри
військові дії Скажем так нам багато чого
вдалося
Скажімо так добитися в даному розвитку
даної сфери нещодавно було ратифікована
угода між Європейським Союзом щодо
розвитку центрів професійної
вдосконалості 10 регіонах країни
значні кошти були виділені як кредитні
такі рамкові Я думаю що на сьогодні
Кожен з нас розуміє наскільки сфера
професійної технічної освіти як і робочі
спеціальності важли країни
момент війни та а також ще важливіші
після
відбудови післявоєнні тому кожен з нас я
вірю роботів себе максимум для нашої
Перемоги для розбудову для досконалення
сфери дуже пишаюсь
цілеспрямованості наших людей які готові
під обстрілами під тяжкими подіями
Скажімо так робити
ще раз дуже вдячний вам зараз сутність
за вашу роботу Разом до перемоги
Дякуємо вам пане Олександре А зараз
Запрошуємо ще одного нашого
надзвичайного партнера
нашого головну підтримку в парламенті
Запрошуємо до слова народного депутата
України голову під комітету з питань
професійно-технічної та фахової
перевищує освіти комітету Верховної Ради
з питань освіти науки та інновацій пані
Ольгу Коваль прошу вас
Доброго дня Щиро вітаю всіх учасників
цьогорічної конференції а також всіх тих
хто нас дивиться онлайн
щорічно Серпнева конференція збирає
освітян для того щоб ми могли поділитися
інформацією і досвідом цьогоріч
незважаючи на складний обставини Ми
також збираємося ми також ділимося
досвідом і будуємо плани як нам
працювати в дуже складних умовах
це уже у нас
восьма або ж навіть дев'ята Вибачте
конференція яка проходить в умовах війни
Росії з України однак цьогорічна
конференція - Це перша після
повномасштабного вторгнення на територію
України
Росії ця війна забирає нас саме
дорогоцінне це життя наших громадян і
саме страшне наших дітей Вона ламає наше
життя багато хто покинув країну багато
людей
виїхавши ми залишили країну і ми
втратили наш людський капітал це дуже
важливо для нас і ми всі працюємо зараз
у дуже складних обставинах з новими
умовами і з новими викликами Кожен з нас
знає суму статистику руйнувань закладів
освіти сьогодні неодноразово багато
спікерів згадували про неї а саме що
страшніше ще раз наголошу ми знаємо
кількості вбитих і поранених дітей
Росією звичайно Все це впливає на наші
настрої наші плани наші цілі на те як ми
будемо працювати у тому числі як ми
організовуємо освітній процес всі
освітяни згуртовані і сильний ми це
побачили побачили як з перших днів
повномасштабного вторгнення на територію
України Росії повномасштабної війни про
всех освітяни згуртувалися про хтось
його освітяни були першими хто почав
зварювати протитанкові їжаки шити
військову амуніцію годувати військових
переселенців ремонтувати техніки і
багато-багато іншого робити для перемоги
над окупантами
Я хочу трішечки у своєму вітальному
слові із антитувати увагу Що робимо ми
як Комітет Верховної Ради для того щоб
такий складний час це система
професійної освіти не просто працювала а
могла і розвиватися незважаючи на все те
що відбувається
я не буду довго розповідати тому що
кожен з вас слідкує і знає що
відбувається і разом з нами напрацьовує
всі ці зміни За це я вам дуже-дуже дякую
Я хочу пригадати законопроект який був
розроблений разом з вами щодо війни Але
який був прийнятий уже під час війни і в
його важливість тільки зросла це
законопроекту 41-47 який запроваджує
часткові кваліфікації і ну і більш
гнучкіші підходи для отримання
професійних кваліфікацій дуже знаковим
для простого освітян став прийнятий
законопроект підписання якого ми дуже
довго чекали президентом це той
законопроект який відновив
справедливість Тобто це звільнення від
мобілізації усіх здобувачів професійної
освіти і викладачів працівників закладів
професійної освіти це дуже важливо тому
що це перш за все Для мене було обурливо
чому є така несправедливість Також ми
внесли зміни до закону про професійну
освіту для того щоб розширити можливість
отримати її усім бажаючим за бюджетні
кошти навіть якщо уже маєш або ж то
спеціальність чи професію раніше яку
отримав і
також внесли зміни щодо зарахування до
закладів професійної освіти незалежно
від місця реєстрації і я знаю що це лише
скажімо наразі більш декларативні зміни
нам потрібно прийняти інший законопроект
це зміни до бюджетного кодексу який
реєструвався в парі з цим законопроектом
ми над цим разом із міністерством
працюємо залучаємо до цього офіс
президента І я надіюся найближчим часом
він буде прийнятий тому що наразі це є
всього лиш частковою зміною також Ми
повернули тривалість відпусток педагогі
і науково-педагогічних працівникам
ухвалили закон який має пришвидшити
трансцифрову трансформацію системи
освіти також системи професійної освіти
це так званий законопроект Про айкон всі
ми також про нього знаємо і те що вже
наголосив Шановний пан заступник
Міністра що є дуже важливим для нас це
ратифікація фінансової угоди між
Україною і європейським інвестиційним
банком за цією угодою ми отримуємо 58
мільйонів євро кредитного фінансування
для створення центрів професійної
досконалості тому я дякую кожному з вас
хто долучається до роботи я дякую
кожному хто працює у своєму закладі тому
хто волонтери і всіма можливими засобами
і силами приближує нашу перемогу над
окупантом тому Дякую колеги Слава
Україні і все буде у нас ПТО
Героям слава каже студія і ми всі
погоджуємося з цим Щиро дякуємо за
підтримку Пані Ольго І власне запій
ініціативи які ви теж запроваджуєте в
рамках діяльності під комітету і
комітету
Ми багато говорили і однієї з проблем
визначаємо професійній освіті Це її
певно непрестижність наявність певного
суспільного стереотипу і якраз з нашими
партнерами з програмою форс Kills Ми
планували цього року на початку року
запустити велику Promo компанію з
популяризації професійної не просто
освіти А взагалі есть популяризації
робітничих професій На жаль війна вона
відкорегувала негативному сенсі наші
плани але вони зупинились ми переглянули
нові підходи до залучили до цього
процесу і сьогодні
почати подальше обговорення ми
пропонуємо з перегляду такого
інформаційного ролика який вже
найближчим часом з'явиться на
телеканалах України і ми сподіваємося
дійсно приверне увагу всіх громадян і
дорослих і молодих до того наскільки
важливо є сфера професійної освіти що
кожна
кожна хвилинка нашого життя залежить
саме Від професіоналів так я гадаю що ми
вже готові до відеоролика прошу ти
завжди досягаєш свого ти щодня дістаєшся
безпечно додому та й новини отримаєш в
будь-який час
маєш свіжі продукти
і снідаєш смачно
виглядаєш чарівно ти знаєш що світ це
робота усіх хто працює з любов'ю
професійно-технічна освіта все працює
завдяки нам
навчайся тому що любиш
Ось так ми пропонуємо всім навчатися
тому що вони люблять бути справжніми
професіоналами і черговий раз
підкреслюємо що дійсно Все працює тільки
завдяки професіоналам які кожного дня
несуть свою акту на своєму робочому
місці Шановні колеги Дозвольте мені
презентувати
твій досягнення які ми отримали за ці
невеликі складні скажімо півроку які
маємо як змінилося сьогодні професійна
освіта які трансформації відбулися Я з
вашого дозволу все ж таки скористаюся
можливістю показати презентацію
сподіваюся що її видно Якщо видно Прошу
дати
відповідний знак і
пройдемося по основним цифрам бо
основним показникам діяльності які на
сьогодні ми маємо ну перш за все в нас є
дуже такі сумні цифри зруйновано під час
збройної агресії з боку Російської
Федерації 10 закладів професійної освіти
103 пошкоджено ми говоримо що ці цифри
неточні це власне тільки те про що ми
знаємо тому що ви прекрасно розумієте що
на окупованих територіях там де ведуться
активні бойові дії порахувати з'ясувати
дізнатися чи кожен заклад цілий на
сьогодні є дуже складно
призупинили свою роботу 9 закладів у
Донецькій області сім закладів
Луганській області
частина з них все ж таки працює
дистанційно ми надзвичайно Дякую всім
всім освітянам незважаючи ні на що
буквально через тиждень після початку
повномасштабного вторгнення
росіяни на території України власне
відновили освітній процес нас повністю
відновлено навчання у 18 областях і
частково у 6 звичайно застосовувалися
різні моделі змішане навчання
дистанційне навчання Але найголовніше те
що ми рухаємося вперед те що Наші учні
здобувають професійну освіту Ми віримо у
велику перемогу але сьогодні що хочемо
говорити про маленькі наші Перемоги у
сфері професійної освіти те що є
попередньо сказала ми дійсно ефективно
організували освітній процес Так Можливо
десь є невдосконалості але на 95%
заклади працюють учні навчають а
підприємства отримують нових
співробітників що є надзвичайно цінно на
сьогодні
дякуючи нашим колегам народним депутатам
було внесено відповідні зміни до
законодавства які зокрема дозволяють
повторно безоплатно навчатися якщо Є
відповідне замовлення з боку місцевої
влади або державне замовлення які
надають можливості здобувати часткові
кваліфікації що значно скорочить термін
навчання і дозволить вже завтра
приступити до виконання своїх обов'язків
ми говоримо про можливість отримання
професійної освіти незалежно від місця
реєстрації а це на сьогодні надзвичайно
актуально тому що ми знаємо велику
кількість внутрішньо переміщених осіб
дітей які вимушені були залишити свої
домівки сьогодні шукають можливості
продовжувати навчання там де вони на
сьогодні оселилися тимчасово Ну і
звичайно це звільнення учнів і педагогів
від примусової мобілізації
наша ще одна велика перемога Це дійсно
залучення 508 мільйонів євро для
створення обласному центрі професійної
досконалості так вони не з'являться
Завтра ми це розуміємо нам треба зважати
на питання безпеки але в будь-якому
випадку ми точно знаємо що
Європейський союз нас підтримує і 9
найновітніших центрів буде створено в
Україні найближчим часом
ми працювали дуже активно на те щоб
відповідно регулювання дозволяли і
розкривало нові можливості або
спрощували певні процеси у сфері
професійної освіти для того щоб наш
освітній процес відбувався згідно до
графіку і
відбувався відповідно до всіх вимог ну
перш за все ми прийняли положення про
внутрішньоекономічну мобільність учнів
професійної освіти це дозволило
це дозволило
336 особам продовжити навчання в інших
закладах на території інших областей ми
спростили процедуру затвердження
регіонального замовлення і на сьогодні в
23-3 регіонах воно вже затверджено
загальним обсягом
87217 осіб ми знаємо що зараз триває
вступна кампанія також йде на зустріч і
продовжуємо її до 1 листопада для того
щоб всі скористалися ті хто ще
виїжджають в безпечні райони тим кому
складно подати хто повертається за
кордону сподіваємося що ці можливості
дійсно нададуть скористатися своїм
правом на здобуття професійної освіти
кожній молоді людині яка завершує школу
з групою або завершила ми продовжили дію
сертифікатів про атестацію це спростило
процедуру замовлення документів
розробили рекомендації як це простіше
легше і правильно зробити в єдиній
державній електронній базі чим теж
зекономили певний час також було
запущено дві промокампанії приклади руку
до вона стартувала з 1 липня і ви бачили
ці цікаві плакатики і все працює завдяки
нам ви сьогодні були на прем’єрі цього
першого проморолику далі наші цікаві
чекають 8 цікавих історій
Міністерство освіти і науки створило
окремо і освітній чат-бот де кожна
людина може ознайо вчитися з купує
інформацію освітніх можливостей де би
вони не знаходились за кордоном чи на
території України чи приміщенні в іншій
області і Ми дякуємо всім хто наповнює
цю інформацію постійно її оновлює також
започатковано проведення безкоштовних
курсів для отримання часткових
кваліфікацій або інших професій для
внутрішнього переміщених осіб
продовжуємо вас всіх інформувати двічі
на місяць відповідно випускаючи дайджест
і коні у комунікують дівчатам що нас
чекає в новому навчальному році за
нашими даними
84,5% закладів професійної освіти готові
розпочати навчання частина з них буде
здійснювати освітній процес очно частина
дистанційної на це є зрозумілі поважні
причини частина буде працювати змішаному
форматі і
цифровізації освіти вона на сьогодні є
надзвичайно затребуваною оскільки ми
розуміємо що організувати ефективно
навчання з високою якістю дистанційно
або навіть змішаному для цього потрібно
Також велика підтримка і наявність
відповідного обладнання
особистих пристроїв гаджетів як зараз
прийнято говорити у здобувачів освіти а
також відповідного обладнання
персонального вчителів на сьогодні ми
забезпечені педагогами на 89 відсотків
це досить непоганий показник Враховуючи
те що частина педагогів теж виїхала
за кордон бо змушені були рятуватися
дискусіях з колегами знаємо що до 1
вересня планують ще повернутися колеги
тому думаємо що будемо укомплектовані
фактично повністю на 1 вересня Ну і
очікуємо що цього року сядуть за парти
продовжують своє навчання і долуче це
243 тися питання учнів з них нового
прийому ми Очікуємо на рівні 86 тисяч
сподіваємося що і
рекламна Наша компанія теж в цьому
посприяє Які ми маємо проблеми безумовно
Це перш за все проблеми з мережею
закладі це як організувати роботу
закладів на тимчасову кованих територіях
чи є зв'язок чи працюємо онлайн
як забезпечити виплату заробітної плати
ці всі питання стоять на сьогодні дуже
гостро не можна сказати що в нас є якісь
універсальний рецепт в кожній області є
свої особливості індивідуально Ми з
усіма пропрацьовуємо але наша все ж таки
головна ціль - це
дозволити
закладам які
прагнуть І абсолютно здійснюють навіть в
окупації супротив тим наказом
які сьогодні надходять від окупантів
хочуть продовжувати навчати за
українськими програмами українською
мовою Наша задача їх максимально
підтримати Ну і звичайно відбудова
зруйнованих закладів Я до речі Дуже
дякую вже почали надходити запитання від
наших глядачів нагадуємо на каналі
YouTube ви можете ставити запитання
писати ваші коментарі я їх буду
максимально озвучувати в ефірі
надійшло власне запитання чи буде
відновлено один із закладів звичайно ми
говоримо про розбудову ефективної мережі
для того щоб рухатися в напрямку
відновлення перш за все треба Део
купувати території певні процеси
реконструкції ремонтів відбудови
закладів не тільки професійної а
загальної середньої освіти вищої освіти
розпочатонати окупованих територіях на
Житомирщині на Київщині на Чернігівщині
Але звичайно якщо ми говоримо про
Луганську Донецьку Херсонську чи
Запорізьку області Миколаївська область
ситуація на сьогодні надзвичайно складна
і ми Очікуємо на стабілізацію
відповідно цієї ситуації і максимально
залучаємо донорів до
підтримки закладів і до їхньої відбудови
Ну і другий найважливіший теж для нас
блок проблем це освітні проблеми як я
вже сказала раніше дистанційне навчання
змішане навчання в одному вимагає
великої кількості цифрового контенту
змісту освіти наявності онлайн-ресурсів
платформ для навчання
техніки відповідно
вирішення питання А як в такому форматі
організувати практику учнів так щоб вони
набули якомога більше практичних навичок
на це в нас теж є відповідні пропозиції
плани ми завершуємо роботу над
онлайн-платформою тому не можу сказати
100%, але дуже хочемо саме 1 вересня
презентувати нову платформу яка буде
орієнтована саме на професійну освіту і
сподіваємося допоможе цього року
працювати
і педагогам і навчатися учням
плани які ми озвучували у плані
відбудови країни Вони теж амбітні Ми їх
поділили умовно на 5 цілей перше це
відбудова відновлення закладів
професійної освіти їх інфраструктури вже
сподіваємося до кінця року ми затвердимо
методичні рекомендації щодо формування
оптимальної мережі Там будуть певні
індикатори формульні розрахунки скільки
повинно бути закладів на тій чи іншій
території як правильно розподіляти
забезпечувати логістично
доїзд до тих чи інших закладів власне
потрібні гуртожитки непотрібні
гуртожитки сподіваємося що цей документ
теж стане такою
дорогу вказом до того як відбудовувати в
подальшому мережу якою вона має бути
скільки закладів Нам потрібно буде ну і
безумовно Будемо продовжувати роботу над
затвердженням регіональних планів
розвитку тепер вони будуть відкориговані
з огляду на ті наслідки які ми маємо вже
на сьогодні і швидше за все ще буде
певні коригування протягом найближчого
часу
так ми плануємо відбудову зруйнованих
закладів профтехосвіти і реконструкції
для всього залучаємо вже зараз і шукаємо
нові ресурси зрозуміло що бюджет України
на сьогодні не
має такої можливості тому що велика
майже весь бюджет власне на сьогодні
зосереджений і направлений на оборону
країни і відвоювання наших територій
тому ми шукаємо поза бюджетні кошти
просимо наших партнерів зосередитись
на цих проектах створення
навчально-практичних центрів Ну і
побудови центри професійної досконалості
також
в напрямку оновлення змісту і підвищення
якості освіти Ми безумовно зосереджуємо
нашу діяльність на розроблені нових
стандартів ми їх до речі більш 15 вже
цього року затвердили і ще 15 планується
підтвердити до кінця року
розроблюємо нові на модульному підході
навчальні програми сподіваємося що ці
навчальні програми теж стануть в нагоді
при підготовці за частковими
компетенціями
короткотермінові програми нас активно
підтримують донори у їх реалізації і в
цьому напрямку теж дуже активні самі
заклади які пропонують купу нових
освітніх можливостей як для переселенців
так і для інших людей які втратили
роботу або змушені були змінити місце
проживання і тепер
ви знаєте кожен регіон має свої
особливості потребують зміни своїх
професій безумовно Це розроблення нових
підручників видання навчальних
матеріалів по тому числі електронних це
ціль 3 це наше власне Створення належних
умов для роботи педагогів це максимально
підтримка онлайн-платформи професійна
освіта онлайн і створення електронного
кабінету вступника до закладу
професійної освіти це розроблення нових
і модернізація наявних програм
підвищення кваліфікації педагогів у тому
числі дистанційному форматі
ціль-4 це забезпечення першочергових
потреб економіки країни у кваліфікованих
кадрів і тут ми активно співпрацюємо з
роботодавцями ми зосереджуємо свою увагу
на популяризації професійної освіти
провадження курсів для безробітних
переселенців удосконалення професійної
роботи
з молоддю профконсультування учнів про
техосвіти Ну і ми розуміємо складність
зараз реалізації програм дуальної форми
але статистика показує що вона ще в нас
збереглася і ми Щиро дякуємо тим
підприємствам які цінують цю форму і
готові в подальшому інвестувати і
розвивати власне дуальне навчання і нова
абсолютно ціль яка виникла в нас після
того як Україна отримала статус
кандидата до ЄС вона тепер є дуже
активною ми мусимо рухатися в напрямку
адаптації українського законодавства про
професію до Європейського збільшувати
присутність і для цього теж окреме
навчання проводимо
навчання українських участі українських
протестів у програмі ЄС размус плюс
повноцінною участі в міжнародному
конкурсі Голд Хиллз і звичайно створення
мережі кваліфікаційних центрів це власне
ці можливо особистості які ми маємо
сьогодні
для тих людей які шляхом неформальної
освіти Чи інформальної освіти вже
здобули певні навички і прагнуть їх
застосувати на ринку праці
я спеціально не заходила в глибокі
деталі Я думаю що для цього у нас буде
додаткові дискусії можливості в нас
сьогодні Таке двогодинне спілкування і
дуже багато цікавих спікерів тому
максимально готова відповідати на
запитання в ході нашої дискусії
щиро дякую всім за увагу сподіваюся що
ця інформація була корисною додатково до
всіх учасників сьогоднішньої нашої
секції інформуємо що на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки буде окрема
закладка окрема те яка в якій будуть
розміщені всі презентації сьогоднішніх
спікерів І власне матеріали нашої
конференції тому будь ласка потім долуча
це можете брати в роботу використовувати
через Дякую за увагу і я би хотіла зараз
передати слово нашій колезі експертці
команди підтримки реформ Міністерства
освіти і науки пані Наталії Проценко бо
я в своїй доповіді спеціально не
приділяла цьому велику увагу але Хочу
наголосити що Підтримка яку ми отримали
з 24 лютого від наших партнерів
міжнародних проектів організації донорів
вона є шаленою і
низький вам клієнт Шановні колеги Щира
вдячність за те що не полишаєте як
приміщений Косів так і наших колег
освітян підтримують їх максимально за
різноманітними напрямками на власне
більш детально Наталочку прошу вас Будь
ласка долучайтеся поділіться з нами
нашими
нашими досягненнями в цій сфері
Доброго дня шановні пані та панове
Шановні колеги дуже приємно всіх вас я
не зовсім бачу але я думаю що
переглянути потім побачив цю таку
спільноту скажіть чи видно презентацію
пані Ірина
дійсно що так склалося певні обставини
умови виклики ресурси які так швидко
змінюються і що сприяють тому що
професійна освіта дійсно повинна не лише
трансформуватися але і відновлюватись
і
дякуючи дійсно нашим міжнародним
партнерам які таку проявили про
активність якраз у підтримки нашої
професійної освіти і цю підтримку можна
отак виокремити в таких напрямках дійсно
це інтеграція в європейській освітній
простори це створення нашої системи
професійної освіти сталої та екологічною
Це дійсно формувати допомога у
формуванні здобувачів професійної освіти
готовності до цифрових і зелених
переходів створення єдиної системи
навчання упродовж життя Що зараз Досить
таке
активно уже набуває таких обертів це
створення умов для мобільності робочої
сили як на національному так
Європейському ринках праці Ну і звичайно
це формування демократичної толерантного
суспільства
проект
програма ой
щоб краще навички для сучасної України
яка розпочала свої кроки з 2019 року за
цей період за цей короткий період цього
року вже має такі
наробки це по-перше розроблення чотирьох
професійних профілів це парад
адаптація 30 польських курсів для онлайн
навчання це створення умов для
використання якраз іт-технології і як
професіях так і підготовки цифрових
компетентностей це розроблення модульних
курсів це закупівля
700 комп'ютерів для закладів
профтехосвіти знову ж таки для того щоб
оці цифрові компетентності могли швидко
швидше формуватися і технічна підтримка
матеріалів для електронної платформи
Програма також
орієнтувалася на те що створилася
інформаційна система управління освітою
еміс розробляються безліч курсів для
педагогічних працівників для керівників
сьогодні актуальним стане створення
кваліфікаційних центрів і програма якраз
розпочинає навчання для потенційних
оцінювачів оцінювачів професійних
кваліфікацій
крім того розробляються короткотермінові
курси для дорослого населення особливо
для
внутрішньо переміщених осіб і якраз
таких професій які актуальними ось
наприклад вже
проведені курси для
кухарів шкіл і садочків для того щоб
започаткувати те харчування про яке
задекларовано і яке дійсно буде сприяти
нашим нашій молоді
програма долучилась до друку підручників
і очікує те що
е-е
підготовку короткотермінового такого
навчання для формування часткових
професійних кваліфікацій А можливо і
мікрокваліфікації за восьми професіями
для
600-700
осіб у 5 вибраних таких регіонах Тобто
це буде один із таких прикладів як можна
диверсифікувати освітні послуги кожному
навчальному закладу використовуючи Ось
такі
короткотерміноване навчання
велике значення програма надає системній
роботі з професійної орієнтацією
сприяли розробленню електронного
кабінету вступника професійної До
закладів професійної освіти підручники
посібники для якраз закладів середньої
освіти орієнтованих на профорієнтацію це
навчання тренерів і вчителів закладів
середньої освіти Ну і як сьогодні вже
було сказано те що запущено дві
промоакції професійної освіти все працює
завдяки нам і приклади руху до тобто я
думаю що ця компанія дійсно буде
привертати не лише вступ до професійної
освіти але і популяризацію робітничих
професій
також
програма долучилася до створення такого
екологічного середовища Для
внутрішньо переміщених осіб в так званих
хабах центрах які їх прийняли це 44
заклади в Львівській області 14 закладів
Чернівецькій області також
ще один наш партнер
і програма по просуванню директиви
Євросоюзу та енергоефективності України
яка також сприяла тому що
по-перше 17 закладах професійної освіти
надано обладнання для проведення
дистанційного навчання ми розуміємо
наскільки це сьогодні важливо Навіть
якщо це буде не дистанційна але змішане
навчання можливість розроблення
симуляторів або тренажерів це
надання
короткотермінових теж навчальних
освітніх програм і ці програми вже
готові до розміщення на
онлайн-платформах це проведення
різноманітних тренінгів навчань для
педагогічних працівників якраз питання
енергоефективності і основна те що ви
знаєте велика дяка за те що зголосилися
надати будівельні матеріали для яка
відновлення пошкоджень трьох пошкоджених
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
ви знаєте приємно те що ось такий
партнери які вже в нас працюють не
перший рік але вони дійсно таких
набувають все Більше таких обертів
по-перше те що
також долучилися до такого екологічного
середовища для внутрішнього переміщених
осіб вони це розуміють і теж вони ось
таких восьми регіонах змогли надати
певну гуманітарну допомогу але що Знаєте
цікаво про те що вперше започатковують
такий унікальний курс навчальний курс
для тих хто потребує або хто хоче надати
першу сантехнічну допомогу знаєте це
досить корисно для кожного з нас мабуть
навіть не просто як кваліфікована
робітника просто пересічних громадян це
продовження роботи тренінги конференції
семінари для педагогічних працівників
для керівників
е-е також про те що
проект продовжує забезпечувати свої
навчально-практичні центри якраз
витратними матеріалами для формування
спеціалістів із сантехнічної
сантехнічного напрямку і дуже приємно що
це один із мабуть таких партнерів який
вже розробили державний освітній
стандарт з професії монтажних
санітарно-технічних систем та
устаткування на часі за ними допомога в
розробленні освітніх програм
Щоб хотілося сказати про те що це
унікальний проєкт який запустив ось
такий інтерактивні підручники у форматі
мобільних застосунків тобто на екрані ви
бачите і можна буде за qr-кодом скачати
ці підручники на свої телефони учні
викладачі і це така допомога дійсно
для спільноти педагогічної і для
учнівської з Такої спільноти крім
можливо сайт який відкритий на якому
акумулюються кращі практики навчальні
освітні освітні матеріали
до поширення і розвитку
санітарно-технічної такої освіти
долучається нова нова компанія німецька
яка також задекларувала бажання створити
центр 3 навчально-практичних центри
за професією монтажника
санітарно-технічних систем та
устаткування і звичайно
в плані підтримки організації навчання в
цих центрах І взагалі на освітнього
процесу
продовжує і велика подяка програмі ООН з
відновлення та розбудови Миру
ви знаєте про те що стільки закладів які
також отримали допомогу для створення
таких умов
позитивних екологічних для внутрішньо
переміщених осіб крім того
програма підготувала і підтримала
Навчання короткотермінове навчання для
таких осіб із професії які можливо
дадуть їм можливість якраз бути
затребуваними на ринку праці навіть не
того регіону де вони раніше проживали
Тобто це така величезна підтримка і ще
одна така унікальна
допомога в тому що мабуть на ринок праці
з'явиться ринку праці з'явиться нова
Професія - це оператор з керування
безпілотних літальних препаратів також
програма закупила ось таких три
квадрокоптери і вже підготувала два
тренера для того щоб можна Можливо в
майбутньому запустити навіть таку
професію
європейські фонд також не стоїть
осторонь для допомоги в трансформації і
відбудові професійної освіти по-перше це
дійсно підготовка матеріалів для
платформи електронної професійної освіти
це ресурси освітні - Це переклад і
створення нових розроблення
короткотермінових курсів для таких
галузей як
енергозбереження будівельна галузь
Зелена енергетика із пілотним проектом
Дніпропетровської області і продовження
співпраці у
моніторингових звітах У подальшому
участі в турецькому процесі а також
впроваджені інструменту
онлайн-інструменти селфі Для
самооцінювання навчальних закладів
Міжнародна організація праці велика
Дякуємо за те що вони долучилися до
створення платформи дистанційного
навчання професійна освіта онлайн
ви ж бачите що вже є перші
наробки які наповнення цієї платформи
Ось вона має такі вигляд де можна
отримати дійсно інформацію для
самонавчання для дистанційного навчання
та самовдосконалення
Ну і далі адаптація також гри для
вивчення іноземної мови Сьогодні ми всі
відчули наскільки актуально кожному
громадянину України володіти
англійською або хоча б однією з
європейських мов
Ну і
міжнародна фундація виборчих систем яка
розробила ось такий курс демократія ідеї
на практиці і де буквально на днях
відбулось величезний такий тренінг за
участю наших працівників закладів
професійної освіти і вони надали і
програми і дидактичні матеріали і з 1
вересня вони
планують запроваджувати пілотування в 12
закладах професійної освіти ви знаєте
Шановні колеги хотілося передати
величезну ушану і подяку нашим
міжнародним партнерам міжнародні
спільноті фундаціям Які вбачають в нас
своїх дійсно потенційних ось таких
партнерів і не тільки професійну освіту
а всеукраїнство і нашу державу яка може
стати повноцінним партнером
Європейського Союзу Дякую за увагу і
всіх нас новим навчальним роком вдалим
спокійним насиченим і ефективним
дякую пані Наталю Ще раз дякую нашим
партнерам ми будемо нескромними ми
сподіваємося на ще більше підтримку тому
що дійсно проблем дуже багато дуже
багато викликів і втрат надзвичайно
багато і нам це все ще треба поповнювати
і удосконалювати
Шановні колеги ми тут в студії передаємо
всім вітання і зараз переходимо до
іншого питання яке не є менш важливим
ніж організація освітнього процесу це
власне питання створення безпечних умов
перебування учасників освітнього процесу
у закладів ми всі знаєте що ми мріємо
повернутися сьогодні за парти
повернутися до школи повернутися до
закладів освіти і
здобувати освіту в наших класах разом з
нашими вчителями з нашими майстрами
майстернях лабораторіях це не просто і я
надзвичайно дякую спасибі пані Олю Це
дійсно
відзначили на вчорашній нараді з
державної служби надзвичайних ситуацій
що заклади професійно-технічної освіти
найкраще готові в плані облаштування
укритів це з одного боку тішить а з
іншого боку звичайно Краще би нам не
доводилося цього всього робити але я
хочу запросити до слова наших колег
сектор мобілізаційної роботи в
цивільного захисту та безпеки
життєдіяльності Міністерства освіти і
науки вони з вами поділяться основними
напрацюваннями рекомендаціями наскільки
практично сьогодні секція зустріч
запрошую зараз за слово завідувача цього
сектору пана Андрія Цимбала прошу вас
Шановні колеги Доброго дня Доброго
здоров'я
пропоную розглянути
наступні питання на нашій секції це
перше питання
[музика]
особливості функціональні функціонування
закладів освіти під час мобілізації
та В умовах воєнного стану перше питання
і друге питання створення безпечних та
нешкідливих умов навчання та праці
учасників освітнього процесу з
урахуванням військової агресії
Російської федерації
по Першому питанню
доповідь головний спеціаліст сектора
який відповідає саме мобілізаційну
роботу за територіальну оборону
Олександр Михайлович і по-другому
питання
доповідь головний спеціаліст сектора
який відповідає за питання цивільного
захисту охорони праці та питання безпеки
життєдіяльності в Італії Міщенко
Шановні колеги у разі виникнення
будь-яких
питань щодо цих напрямів роботи прошу
звертатись в подальшому не тільки під
час роботи нашої секції до сектору
мобілізаційної роботи цивільного захисту
та безпеки життєдіяльності для надання
відповідних вам рекомендацій роз'яснення
питань нормативних документів
тощо
До речі до першого питання прошу до
слова Олександра Михайлова
Добрий день шановні колеги коротко
зупинюсь на особливостях функціонування
закладів освіти під час мобілізації та В
умовах воєнного стану
метою забезпечення під час мобілізації
та В умовах воєнного стану реалізації
державних гарантій у сфері освіти та
виконання закладу освіти завдань щодо
задоволення потреб національної
економіки
населення законодавством України
передбачено
виконання закладів освіти мобілізаційних
завдань на підготовку фахівців для
забезпечення функціонування національної
економіки в особливий період
звільнення від призову на військову
службу під час мобілізації на особливий
період визначених категорій учасників
освітнього процесу перелік яких
визначений статеві 23 закону України Про
мобілізацію яку вже наголошувалась серед
цієї категорій також є здобувачі
професійної
професійно-технічної освіти а також
педагогічні працівники В закладів
професійної професійно-технічної
зрозуміти за умови що вони працюють за
основним місцем роботи не менше як на
0,75 ставки
передбачена також можливість бронювання
військовозобов'язаних які працюють у
закладах освіти але не звільняється від
призову на військову службу згідно
закону цей порядок бронювання визначений
постановою Кабінету Міністрів України
від 3 березня 22-го року номер 194 і
міністерством розроблений відповідний
алгоритм бронювання
за цією постановою який розміщений на
офіційному веб-сайті Міністерства освіти
і науки України у розділі Міністерства
діяльність мобілізаційна робота
слід також зазначити що в умовах
воєнного стану військовим командуванням
разом із військовими адміністраціями на
місцях можуть запроваджуватись та
здійснюватися заходи щодо використання
потужності закладів освіти усіх форм
власності для потреб оборони
хочу зауважити що листом Міністерства
освіти і науки від 15 червня цього року
начальники обласних Київської міської
військових адміністрацій було
повідомлено щодо необхідності
забезпечення можливості функціонування
закладів освіти та провадження ними
освітньої діяльності під час прийняття
відповідних рішень
зважаючи на викладений просимо при
запровадженні та здійсненні усіх
перелічених заходів врахувати що
почергово першочерговим завданням
керівників всіх рівнів на сьогодні є
забезпечення можливості функціонування
закладів освіти створення умов для
провадження ними статутної діяльності
Дякую за увагу Шановні колеги
і по другому питанню передаю слово
Віталій Міщенко
[музика]
Добрий день шановні присутні хочу
подякувати за можливість звернутися до
спеціалістів які готують на потреби
нашої держави фахівців робітничих
професій
головним пріоритетом до нас залишається
і це закріплене Конституцією України
людина її життя і здоров'я честі
гідність недоторканість і безпека що
визначають та в Україні найвищий
соціальні цінності статтям 53-54 закону
Про освіту визначено що здобули честі
йти наукову науково-педагогічний та
педагогічний працівники мають право на
безпечні нешкідливі умови навчання
утримання і праці імовірність повітряних
ударів або теоретичних актів внаслідок
збройної агресії Російської Федерації
залишається значно високою у разі
організації роботи заклади освіти
звичайним очному режимі необхідно
передбачені безпечному праці та порядок
дій учасника освітнього процесу на
випадок оголошення повітряної тривоги
або іншої загрози як наприклад загроза
виникнення надзвичайної ситуації на
об'єктах що зберіга небезпечні речовини
то знаходяться поблизу закладу освіти
якнакша наприклад з залізничний вузол
або залізнична станція де можуть
переміщуватися небезпечний вантажі з
метою організації підготовки закладів
освіти до нового навчального року
забезпечення проходження ними сильних
зимового періоду 20-23 року
створення безпечних умов перебування в
закладах освіти дітей участь студентів і
працівників з урахуванням збройної
агресії Російської Федерації 7 червня
поточного року було проведення нараду
під головуванням прем'єр-міністра
України де було з питань в тому числі з
приведення готових до використання за
призначення укртів фонду захисних споруд
цивільного захисту на виконання
доручення прем'єр-міністра України в
регіоні було організовано роботу
відповідних комісій з огляду оцінки
будівництва руд переміщення заклади
освіти де планується організувати
освітні процеси в режимі офлайн у всіх
регіонів відомще належалості
на наявності відповідних укриків
Хочу зазначити що вже сьогодні
говорилось про це що станом на тепер
проведено комісійних обстежень і це
найкращі показник серед складників
освіти
91% об'єктів будівлі закладів про ціни
про ціни технічної освіти
забезпечення укриття укриттям фонду
захисних споруд цивільного захисту 69%
об'єктів будівлі закладів освіти не
передбачається розпочати освітні процес
режимі офлайн які дозволять укрити 57%
учасника освітнього процесу вони робота
відповідних комісій ще не завершення
триває і буде е-е Я сподіваюсь що станом
на 25 серпня дещо покращені показники
крім наявності укриті та проведення
практичне триває на випадок оголошення
повітряної трилогії або інші загрози
хотів би звернути увагу на реалізацію
інших безпеках питань до яких ми звикли
ще за часів організації освітнього
процесу в мирний час на виконанням вимог
положення Про організацію роботи з
охорони праці та безпеки життєдіяльності
сучасників освітнього процесу установах
і закладах освіти затверджує наказом
міністерства від 26 грудня 17-го року
номер
1669 перед початком навчань один раз на
рік а також при зарахування оформлення
до закладу освіти здобувача освіти
проводиться вступний інструктаж з
безпеки життєдіяльності служби охорони
праці безпеки життєдіяльності за умови
чисельності учасників освітнього процесу
закладах понад 200 осіб вищезазначені
служби проводиться навчання з
вихователів класоводами класними
керівниками майстерним виробничого
навчання куратором і груп тощо Які в
свою чергу і структурують здобувачів
освіти перед початком навчального року
крім того мають бути проведені первинні
з безпеки життєдіяльності на початку
заняття у кожному кабінеті лабораторії
майстерні в спортзалі тощо перед
початком канікул а також за межами
закладу освіти для освітній процес
пов'язано з використанням небезпечних
або шкідливих для здоров'я факторів
зазначений інструктажі мають містити
питання охорони здоров'я пожежної
техногенної радіаційної безпеки
цивільного захисту безпеки дорожнього
руху реагування надзвичайних ситуацій
безпеки при роботі на устаткування та
механізми з механізми а також безпеки у
побуті
на завершення Хотів до свого виступу
хотів би подякувати кожному працівникові
закладу освіти За мужність і відданість
які забезпечать освітній процес в умовах
коли постійно лунають сигнали тривоги та
вибухи А в деяких регіонах досі тривають
активні бойові дії побажати і надалі
якісно виконувати свої обов'язки на
своїх посадах створюють умови для
навчання здовольчої освіти адже
здійснення освітнього процесу в закладах
освіти важливо ознака життєздатності
України а Підготовка фахівців робітничих
професій буде сприяти і неї скоріше та
якісно відбитові нашої держави Всім
дякую за увагу якщо будуть запитання
будь ласка готова до до дискусії і
співбесіди дякую
Дякуємо друзі Шановні колеги ми
отримуємо ваші запитання ми маємо
ми маємо трошки часу наприкінці нашої
секції для обговорення тих питань які
для нас для нас надходять в чату я зараз
хочу перейти до іншого питання яке є не
менш важливішим оскільки безпека для нас
сьогодні це понад усе а друге питання
дійсно наш наше наше все зміст і якість
професійної освіти і ми знаємо як важко
було організувати роботу в цій тяжкі
часи але знаємо що майже всі я би
сказала всі
впоралися з цим на відмінно
і ми хочемо сьогодні поділитися кращими
практиками дати загальний огляд як
працюють регіональні системи професійної
освіти наразі мені хочеться
розпочати цю низку виступів з виступу
Валентини Олександрівна радкевич доктора
педагогічних наук професора дійсно його
члена Національної академії педагогічних
наук України директори інституту
професійної освіти Національної академії
педагогічних наук України
Валентина Олександрівна нам сьогодні
розкаже про науково-методичний супровід
розвитку професійної освіти в умовах
воєнного і повоєнного часу прошу вас
Доброго дня
Сердечно вітаю усіх учасників нашої
всеукраїнської серпневої конференції від
себе особисто і від наукового колективу
інституту професійної освіти
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України єдиної науковою установою яка
забезпечує науковий методичний супровід
розвитку професійної та фахової
передвищує освіти
безумовно що цей рік розпочинається в
дуже складних умовах і відомо що от саме
це
повномасштабне вторгнення Росії в
Україну
надзвичайно детермінувало таких
потужні виклики перед системою
професійної освіти серед яких
найважливіших якби отримати те що
змінюється вектори розвитку саме
економічного розвитку нашої держави в
умовах воєнного стану і безумовно ми
маємо враховувати те що нас очікує
воєнній економіці дуже серйозні
руйнування відбулися інфраструктури
закладів професійної освіти що призвело
до значної втрати найсучаснішого
матеріально-технічної бази а також
навчально-методичного забезпечення
освітнього процесу
безумовно що ославилися партнерські
зв'язки з роботодавцями що негативно
позначиться на організацію виробничої
практики дуального професійного навчання
в умовах виробництва Ну і безумовно що
великим викликом є це значить втрати
контингенту та кадрові проблеми
пов'язані із тим що багато залишилося
людей на тимчасово окупованих територіях
внутрішньо переміщені вже сьогодні
говорилося що багато виїхало за кордон
Але незважаючи на ці виклики
професійна освіта стає на ноги і починає
розвиватися і шукати шляхи свого
розвитку і за таких умов
науково-методичний супровід є дуже
важливим у виході з системи професійної
освіти з такої системної воєнної кризи у
зв'язку з цим інститут професійної
освіти активізував своє таку взаємодію з
тими найважливішими партнерами це
насамперед директоратом професійної
освіти Міністерства освіти і науки
України
навчально-науково-методичними центрами
комітетом з питань науки і освіти та
інновації Верховної Ради України
закладами освіти міжнародними партнерами
та роботодавцями слід зауважити що попри
військовий стан науковий працівники
спільно з роботодавцями займається
розробленням професійних стандартів з
актуальних на ринку праці професії
будівельного профілю та сфери
обслуговування починаючи з перших днів
війни науковці інституту розпочали
проводити
онлайн-тренінги онлайн вебінари онлайн
семінари для наших педагогічних
працівників для того щоб їх підтримати
складну таку от хвилину в складний час і
допомогти їм дати певні інструменти для
того щоб вони були їх скористатися ними
діяльності своєї і в організації
освітнього процесу зокрема розпочали
навчати розробляти застосовувати
дистанці
йні модернізувати інформаційно-освітнє
середовище надавати психологічну
підтримку суб'єктам освітнього процесу
забезпечувати
охорону і захист персональної інформації
та персональної даних мережі Інтернет В
умовах воєнного стану забезпечувати
формування громадянських цінностей у
молоді і дуже-дуже багато інших
тематиках актуальних які допомогли їм
організовувати функціонування закладів
професійної освіти у воєнний час
окрім того слід зауважити що
інститутом підготовлено значний перелік
нових електронних видань для закладів
професійної освіти з дуже актуальних
тематик і організації підготовки молоді
та підприємницької діяльності і
безумовно з Основи економічної
грамотності підготовлена навчальні
підручники технологія верстатних робіт
та технологія звернення фасадних
будівель і багато інших які ви бачите на
слайді не будуть зачитувати але всі вони
є в відкритому доступі і може
скористатися кожен педагог
без організації освітнього процесу у
підготовці кваліфікованих робітників для
того щоб якимось чином допомогти нашій
системі професійної освіти протистояти
тим викликам складним інститут
професійної освіти переорієнтував свої
дослідження з фундаментальних на
прикладні і результатами цих прикладних
досліджень буде і вже починає
розроблятися дуже цікава тематика це
технології і методики розвитку
державного приватного партнерства В
умовах воєнного та повоєнного часу
професійна підготовка майбутніх кваліфі
соціальних робітників в умовах змішаного
навчання тому що дуже багато закладів
сьогодні переходять на цю форму
застосування цифрових і еко-орієнтованих
технологій у підготовці кваліфікованих
робітників цінними є дослідження
технології методики консультування з
молодіжного підприємництва у воєнний та
повоєнний час і безумовно Це
професій працівників тих нестандартних
умовах функціонування закладів
професійної освіти а саме В умовах
пандемії воєнного та повоєнного часу
для підтримки наукового потенціалу наших
освітян ми в інституті
забезпечили безоплатне публікування
своїх статей своїх інноваційних таких
розробок у науково-метричному журналі
професійна педагогіка ці статті які ви
зараз бачите в останньому номері теж є
дуже актуальні для закладів професійної
освіти вони є в відкритому доступі їх
можна скачувати і використовувати у
своїй діяльності
не припиняв свою своє видання журнал
відомий для усіх простих освітян
науково-методичний журнал професійна
освіта якщо ви бачите на слайді то ви
мабуть зрозуміли що ми отут показуємо не
тільки те що робиться інноваційним в
системі професійної освіти але і ті
проблеми які ми сьогодні маємо і з якими
ми сьогодні
боремося для того щоб їх подолати на
цьому слайді ми спеціально показали на
першій сторінці обкладинці журналу
професійна освіта зруйнований
професійний ліцей міста Василькова який
якщо ви подивитеся внизу тут є дві
фотографії
до війни в якому стані була сучасна
матеріально-технічна база цього закладу
і зараз який він зруйнований безумовно
великі втрати дуже
сумно від цих втрат але сподіваємося що
це все відродиться і
це професійна освіта
переможе у своєму у своїй розбудові у
своєму розвитку за допомогою безумовного
освітнього пані Наталія казала і
міжнародних партнерів і наших
роботодавців Не менш важливим є те що ми
сьогодні започаткували продовжили на
нове видання для висвітлення
експериментальних досліджень особливо
тих які здійснюється на всеукраїнському
рівні спільно з педагогічними
працівниками закладів професійної освіти
перше видання такого
продовженого видання
інноваційно-професійна освіта присвячена
формування готовності майбутніх
кваліфікованих робітників до
підприємницької діяльності у цьому
виданні будуть представлені авторські
розробки наших педагогів закладів
професійної освіти
цінними є також результати міжнародного
проекту в якому
професійна освіта і наш інститут
реактивну участь це
размус Плюс погости який цілісно
спрямований на допомогу професійній
освіті в рамках цього проекту
оновлюється професійний стандарт педагог
професійного навчання з метою розширення
його компетентностей В загальних так і
професійних а також розробляється
унікальна веб-платформа партнерських
простір 0,15 яка буде дійсно такою
платформою комунікації між ринком
освітніх послуг та ринком праці для того
щоб можна було і професійно розвиватися
педагогам і шукати роботу і шукати
підвищення кваліфікації а роботодавцям
знаходити для своїх робочих місць
кваліфікованих робітників Слід зазначити
що великий плати вважаю є підготовлені
для закладів професійної освіти
науковцями інституту
Науковій науково-методичній навчальні та
виробничо-практичні видання різного
характеру і щодо організації
дистанційного навчання і запровадження
інноваційних проєктних технологій і
проектного менеджменту в закладах
професійної освіти і розроблення
смартфонів навчальних дисциплін І
започаткування і впровадження дуального
професійного навчання тобто самі
різноманітні тематики актуальні які
сьогодні є і потрібні для закладів
професійної освіти ви теж можете знайти
на нашому сайті для спеціально на
презентацію висвітлила адресу сайту
безкоштовно у такому відкритому доступі
можете їх заскачувати використовувати і
надавати свої рекомендації що вам ще
потрібно для того щоб ви могли успішно
працювати цінним також є сайт педагог
новатор на якому ми представляємо
унікальні авторські розробки
педагогічних працівників закладів
професійної та фахової передвищої освіти
на сайті нашому є презентації є відео і
все це відкритому доступі користуйтеся і
ми тільки будемо раді допомогти і
забезпечити цей науковий методичний
супровід у цьому році я думаю що це вже
буде жовтень листопад будуть видані
електронні видання нові саме з
молодіжного підприємництва В умовах
воєнного стану з розроблення валідних
тестів які можна використовувати в
закладах професійної освіти щодо
забезпечення оцінювання якості
підготовки кваліфікованих робітників
запровадження еко-орієнтованих і
цифрових технологій а також
запровадження державного приватного
партнерства у системі професійної освіти
ви мабуть побачили що ми вже відійшли
від тих паперових підручників посібників
мето процес рекомендацій теж перейшли на
електронні видання які можна буде
використовувати на різних платформах ці
що створюються і можна доповнювати ті що
створюються нашими міжнародними
партнерами Тобто їх вже в електронному
вигляді можна використовувати
кругом
хочу сказати що ми брали активну участь
в розробленні інновації до проекту плану
відновлення Української новації два
національних проекти єдина система
професійної освіти та ефективна мережа
закладів професійної освіти для
повоєнних потреб особистості суспільства
економіки Я вважаю що реалізація цих
проектів якщо вони дійсно будуть
прийняті воно буде сприяти по-перше
він
можна так сказати Не виникненню а
уникненню оцієї отого дублювання яке
сьогодні існує в Україні у системі
професійної професійно-технічної освіти
та фахової передвищує освіти доболювання
відбувається в системі в центрі
професійно-технічної освіти державної
служби зайнятості і якщо ми приберемо ці
дублювання а з прямуємо кошти державні і
кошти
обласних бюджетів на підготовку тих
фахівців які дійсно будуть потрібні
повоєнній економіці це буде тільки на
користь нашій державі і нашій
професійній освіті
ми як науковці
відкриті завжди ми завжди готові
співпрацювати надавати науково-методичні
супровід усім без виключення
педагогічним колективам тому просимо
звертайтеся до нас е-е пишіть нам
давайте свої пропозиції які б ви хотіли
щоб ми зробили дослідження Ми сьогодні
розпочали велике дослідження моніторингу
закладів професійної та фахової
передвищої освіти вже завершили це зараз
ми поєднуємо з тим що вимагає від нас
ринок праці тобто буде безумовно
з'ясовано дуже багато наших таких
перспектив які можна буде розв'язати
уникнувши тих негараздів які сьогодні є
на ринку освітніх послуг і тим самим
посприяти розвитку нашої економіки всім
Бажаю миру бажаю сили духу вистояти і
Перемоги на нашому як освітянському
фронті так і на нашому все національному
варіанті заради незалежності України
слава Україні героям слава
[музика]
Валентину Олександрівна за дійсно фахове
наукове обґрунтування я наукові підходи
до формування змісту професійної освіти
і зараз якраз хочеться перейти до
практики і Я запрошую до слова якщо
можна вакцину олександрівну припиніть
зараз трансляцію вашого екрану ви
згорнули презентацію зараз ще припиніть
трансляцію а Я запрошую до слова власне
тих хто кожного дня в сфері освіти
продовжує
на свою роботу І власне наших колег тих
хто нас сьогодні приймають у
прекрасному закладі на Вінниччині Я
запрошую до слова пані Анжелу Москалюк
начальника відділу науки вищої
професійної фахової передвищої освіти
управління освіти і науки Департаменту
гуманітарної політики Вінницької
обласної наразі військової адміністрації
пані Анжела вам слово зараз презентацію
теж спробуємо продемонструвати
Дякую
я поки буде демонструватися моя така
невеличка презентація для того щоб було
легше візуально
сприймати інформацію я хочу все-таки
подякувати
свої обіцяли що на Вінниччині буде
проведена сесія звичайно на превеликий
жаль що ми проводимо не в такому
можливому форматі якби нам хотілося Але
я думаю що сьогодні наша робота та
завдання яке Ми поставили перед собою
так мета мої досягнемо і ти напрацювання
вони покладуть нам план роботи всіх нас
на наступний навчальний рік і звичайно з
вірою в мир в перемогу і про те що ви
все все буде в нас гаразд і буде просто
освіта Дякую за можливість сьогодні
виступити і ознайомити колег із нашим
досвідом роботи закладів системи
професійно-технічної освіти в умовах
воєнного і тепла передбачення повоєнний
період Вінницька область ми аграрний
регіон
29 закладів професійно-технічної освіти
три навчальних центрів плюс установах
виконання покарань хвалити Богу В нас
всі заклади збережені функціонують і
відповідно
завершили освітні процеси
в повному складі зрозуміло страта мету
контингенту які сьогодні потрібно батьки
вирішили виїхати і звичайно дистанційно
в змішаній формі ми зуміли завершити
освітній процес це майже півтори тисячі
освітян які працювали на освітянській
Ниві і сьогодні готові розпочати до
нових навчальний рік звичайно було не
просто викликали виклики які стояли це
завершити навчальний рік але ми спільно
завер як випустили майже більше 4000
кваліфікованих робітників і 125 фахівців
вчасно видали документи проведели
провели кваліфікаційні атестації
звичайно Ми зіткнулися з новими
проблемами але я хочу подякувати і нашим
керівникам директорам закладів системи
про тих освіти Вінниччини які як один
зуміли
зробити і вчасно завершити в цьому році
теж освітній процес згідно тих робочих
навчальних планів звичайно Сьогодні
ми працюємо ми не зупиняємося і в з
перших днів Звичайно це
враховуючи і систему фінансування яка
сьогодні на Вінниччині системи оскільки
в нас 8 закладів системи профтехосвіти
фінансуються з бюджету Вінницької
міської територіальної громади 20
закладів фінансується з обласного
бюджету і три заклади фінансуються з
державного сюжету Відповідно ми коли
планували регіональне замовлення на 22-й
рік дякувати що сьогодні ми спростили
Нам процедуру в період воєнного періоду
ми
намагались не зменшувати показники
регіонального замовлення на 22-й рік і
спланували майже на рівні
21-21 року відповідно сьогодні
станом уже на сьогоднішній день
виконання регіонального замовлення
складає
85%, якщо порівнювати з минулим роком це
82% державного замовлення в професії
загальнодержавного значення це 82%. ну і
фахівців ми вже виконали майже на 104
відсотки звичайно знову ж таки стало
питання ми намагалися сьогодні
найшли на збільшення регіонального
замовлення але сьогодні ми вже бачимо по
формування приймальними комісіями нас і
вступають діти із внутрішньо переміщених
категорій Ми сьогодні сподіваємося що
якщо буде навіть перевиконання А ми це
відчуваємо ми зуміємо знайти той ресурс
для того щоб задовільнити всіх потреби
для наших здобувачів абітурієнтів для
навчання в закладах системи
професійно-технічної освіти
Я хочу сказати що заклади
професійно-технічну освіту Ми звичайно В
умовах
воєнного стану і провели і вчасно і
атестацію педагогічних працівників
керівних кадрів тобто вважаємо що це
наша наш фронт роботи і ми мали йти в
нову із тими планами спершу від міф
агресії заклади системи професійної
освіти зокрема гуртожитки стали центрами
для внутрішнього переміщених як для
транзитних осіб так і стали сьогодні
певної домівкою до сьогодні вони
проживають сьогодні
працюємо над тим як для тимчасово
проживання
довготривалий період і звичайно за
рахунок коштів донорів Ми намагаємося
сьогодні створити їм належні умови і для
того щоб і забезпечити і належний
освітній процес надаючи
робітничу кваліфікацію для наших
наших здобувачів освіти звичайно для
їдальнях були організовано і харчування
внутрішньо переміщених осіб відповідно
як уже сьогодні казали колеги приступили
з перших днів до виготовлення продукції
для потреб збройних сил Це і задіяні і
швачки наші і зварники і кухарі і
слюсарі і звичайно
Сьогодні ми готові виконувати будь-які
завдання які перед нами стоять перед
системою про тих освіти це не дивлячись
вчити педагог чи ти майстер чи технічний
працівник звичайно як
дивлячись на майбутнє на початок
напередодні Ми всі з вами 1 вересня
початку нового навчального року це
звичайно готовність і безпечні умови так
дійсно сьогодні всі зусилля прикладені
для того щоб ми
укриття які
в свій час вони були в нас але приведені
в належні до вимог час для того щоб ми
могли забезпечити освітній процес як ми
будемо здійснювати з 1 вересня Звичайно
що сьогодні йдуть такі остаточних рішень
немає але є певна дискусія ми сьогодні
маємо згуртувати в першу чергу перший
курс для того щоб не втратити його в
майбутньому Звичайно це і використання
змішаної це і дистанційної форми
навчання Ну і звичайно з метою
подальшого
виконання робочих планів
заклад про втехосвіти це звичайно
заклади які має свою частку доходів і ми
цей показник сьогодні теж тримаємо на
контролі тому що 21-22 навчальний рік
показує що ми втратили і значну частку
через зменшення
дохідної частини оскільки
дохідна частина закладу системи про тих
освіти це є бюджет розвитку для того щоб
можна було оновлювати
сучаснувати нашу матеріальну базу Ви
можете бачити показникам що Ми все-таки
тримаємо ось цей
намагаємося утримати ще за півроку ми
вже узагальнили цифри але сподіваємося
що за наступних пів року ми зуміємо
Вийти на показники рівня хоча би 21-го
року звичайно дуальна форма навчання ми
її сьогодні теж тримаємо на пульсі тому
що
аналізуючи з попередніми ми десь дуальна
форма навчання дала нам подих для наших
закладів для можливості
підготовки наших здобувачів освіти
проходження виробничих практик на
сучасному обладнанню проаналізувавши За
останні півроку ми бачимо певну
тенденцію до зменшення і кількість
закладів які задіяні задіяли дуальну
форму навчання кількість професій і
кількість роботодавців і кількість
здобувачів зокрема ми знаходимося в
козятинському
навчальному вищому професійному училищі
Ви можете бачити це гарний досвід
співпраці із
таким каоліновим підприємством
українська де саме ініціативи і
керівника закладу зуміли створити
матеріальну базу саме для професії
слюсар-електрик задіявши майже 26
мільйонів да підприємство сьогодні теж
переживає певні моменти труднощі але
сьогодні все рівно про планується і
перспектива на майбутнє для того щоб
підготувати підготувати саме на
підприємствах сучасних і готувати
сучасних фахівців Ну і хочеться сьогодні
подякувати нашим все-таки міжнародна
діяльність яка на Вінниччині Вона має
свою гарну історію і має свої традиції
це величезна кількість партнерів до 15
країн світу і
звичайно міжнародна діяльність вона
особливо фонд ембергарда що треба
баден-баден Німеччина які
й частині модернізації
закладу будівельного профілю надали і
підтримку і в ковідний період і
військовий час оновленню
матеріально-технічної бази яка сьогодні
стала приском для внутрішньо переміщених
осіб також дякуючи Міністерство освіти
Ми реалізували ще напередодні військової
агресії такі швейцарські
проект спільно із гібрид і модернізували
гуртожиток на базі вищого художнього
професійно-технічного училища №5 міста
Вінниці
осучаснивши це для закладів для
гуртожитків міста Вінниці і Вінниччини
це таке знаєте осучаснення простору для
проживання наші здобувачі з цілодобовим
перебуванням Дана превеликий жаль
Можливо ми не мали можливості наші
здобувачі ще
насолодитися цими оновленими
кімнатами просторовими але сьогодні вони
приймають внутрішньо переміщених осіб і
це теж це наші люди Ми маємо теж
забезпечити Ну і звичайно наші партнери
його Skills оскільки Вінниччина ми
увійшли до складу семи областей Ми
хочемо подякувати ту підтримку то і
регіонального
координатора яка тісно співпрацює
Сьогодні ми працюємо в частині Я не хочу
повторюватись із забезпечення
надання фінансової допомоги ось Ми
плануємо вже буквально на визначено що
невизначена дата для вручення таких
обладнання де приймають ті закладах а
нас це 16 закладів внутрішнього
переміщених осіб щоб покращити їхні
умови умови проживання Ну і я хочу
сказати що Шановні колеги подякувати за
можливість що освіта Вінниччини - Це ось
той фронт який ми трима ми можемо і
готові тримати
Ми сьогодні спілкуємося з керівниками і
дивимося на майбутнє в пошуках тих
професії які потрібні будуть для
відбудови нашої країни і ми готові
сьогодні працювати І осучаснювати і
робочі навчальні плани програми і
звичайно нашу освітній процес в плані
виховної роботи тому що це теж дуже
значна складова серед наших здобувачів і
сподіваємося що
ті завдання які стоять виклики перед
закладами системи професійно-технічної
освіти Вінницької області вони ми
зуміємо їх подолати тому що масивні Ми
впевнені і віримо що буде мир і перемога
Дякую за увагу
Дякуємо пані Анжелу і в нас така
мобільна студія сьогодні
крім Вінниччини свої результати ще
представить Хмельниччина і Львівщина
зараз Дозвольте теж передати слово нашій
колезі
начальнику відділу вищої
професійно-технічної позашкільної освіти
і науки управління освіти і науки
Департаменту освіти науки молоді та
спорту Хмельницької Обласної військової
адміністрації пані Світлані киярський
яка власне познайомить нас з абсолютно
новим підходом до
співпраці закладів освіти різних рівнів
І власне розкаже про їхній досвід
започаткування
освітніх хабіб прошу розповідь дякую
пані Ірина Доброго дня шановні колеги
коротенько про таку освіту Хмельницької
області наразі в області функціонує 26
закладів професійно-технічної освіти з
них три заклади навчальних при установах
виконання покарань заклади є як
агропромислового спрямування
з перебування сфери послуг тобто маємо
різний напрямки роботи
зрозуміло що коли розпочалась війна вона
нас всіх заставила вчитися жити в Нових
умовах хтось вчився жити
скажімо хтось вчився навчатися в цих
умовах А ми якось освітяни мали вчитися
навчати і виховувати в цих умовах і не
забути про те що ми освітяни
міністерством освіти і науки України
спільно з державною науковою
установкового інститут модернізації
змісту освіти та асоціації інновацій
строкової освіти ініціювали створення
мережі освітній хабіб у західних
регіонах голова нашої військової
адміністрації відкликнувся на Цю
пропозицію і оскільки вже на початку
березня в нашій області налічувалось
біля 109
129 тисяч внутрішньо переміщених осіб
такій освітній хаб вирішили відкрити у
нашому регіоні
зрозуміло ми в деякій мірі розуміли що
це таке але до кінця реалізацію І як
воно буде
ми до кінця не знали але Дякуємо
координаторам освітнього хабу які
працюють у нас і зараз
функціонують в Хмельницькій області Ми
зуміли зробити таку
реалізацію у цього проекту діяльність
храму в першу чергу була спрямована
українців працездатного віку новин
професіям необхідним навичкам
енергобраті крім того важливим були
інтеграція та підтримка переселенців І
тут вже освіта та додаткові творчі
заняття надихались спонукали до розвитку
підтримували духовно дозволяли перенести
увагу з побутових справ на активізацію
внутрішніх ресурсів на перші дні хаву
вже було організовано 14 послуг це
підвищення кваліфікації освітян з
психологічної допомоги
профоритаційні курси тестування щодо
визначення власних здібностей до
професій навчання української
англійської мови першої медичної
допомоги Ну і головне - це
короткострокові курси 2-3 тижня
актуальним професіям як для місцевих
мешканців які у нас в області втратили
роботу так і для внутрішньо переміщених
осіб Ну і відповідно до проведення і
навчання таких курсів залучилися
запропонували залучитися і залучилися
професійно-технічної освіти області
долучилися всі заклади області
чому говорю Всі так зрозуміло першими
перші прохідцями були заклади обласного
центру
міста Хмельницького оскільки там
найбільше дислокувалися внутрішньо
переміщених осіб Але залучали ми всі
заклади оскільки це нам давали
можливість географічно покрити всю
область і охопити всіх бажаючих які
прибули на нашу область до надання таких
послуг
нами була розроблена разом із освітнім
хабом таблиця яка
містила перелік закладів і перелік тих
курсів які може надавати заклад велася
широка інформаційна кампанія Це
розміщувалася як на сайтах так і в
певних пунктах де було
організовані кол-центри гуманітарні
центри для внутрі дослідження
переміщених осіб і безпосередньо в самих
навчальних закладах Отож за цей час що
ми працювали заклади
професійно-технічної освіти
зуміли організувати і
навчання за кордоном
пройшли 543 особи із внутрішньо
переміщених осіб які отримали
сертифікати і часткові кваліфікації з
професії закрійник Кравець Швачка
кухар-кондитер тісторок манікюрних
перукар адміністратор
діловод-лицювальних плиточних монтажних
тобто у нас було організовано 48
напрямків з професій потреба була в
організації цих курсів не тільки тому що
людину заохочути так і дати їм
можливість себе знайти у новому а й тому
що в нашу область також релаксували
підприємства з інших регіонів які
постражда немає військової агресії і
вони вже знаходились на нашій території
області і потребували саме
робітничих кадрів
тому ми завжди дослуховувались до
пропозицій
роботодавців ішли їм на зустріч
закликали всіх бажаючих отримувати
професію крім того як вже казали
попередній спікери в рамках
реалізації програми ООН з відновлення та
розбудову Миру за фінансової підтримки
Європейського Союзу та інформаційної
підтримки освітнього хабу Ми також
здійснювали короткотермінове навчання за
професією Швачка у Хмельницькому
професійному ліцеї лісоруб
ярмолинецькому агропромисловому центрі
професійної освіти і
електрозварник у вищому професійному
училищі номер 11 і варто відзначити що
всі ці особи їх біля 60 вони коли
працевлаштовані і це Саме основне ми
вважаємо таких вагомих досягнень що ми
могли не тільки навчити людину а й далі
працевлаштувати дати їй можливість
знайти себе в житті я можу дуже багато
говорити і хвалитися так як кожна
область напевно і кожен заклад
професійно-технічної освіти Ми всі
волонтери Але ми всі наразі Продовжуємо
Це робити ми надаємо Бо сильно допомогу
в усіх рамках як тільки можливі як і
психологічної освітньої такти до
фінансової матеріальної
продуктової Тобто це різні аспекти але
наразі приємно що в рамках цього
освітнього Хаба ми для закладі
професійно-технічної освіти зробили і
потужно профоритаційну інформаційну
кампанію тому що на сьогоднішній день ми
бачимо що
рейтинг професійно-технічної освіти
і саме здобуття цієї освіти нашій
області ну пішов догори Скажімо так тому
що люди самі зрозуміли з вищою освітою
щоб вони отримали тут пройшли то
навчання але вони все мають можливість
заробляти отримувати кошти і як сьогодні
пані Ірина казала що розпочинається нова
дома акція навчайся тому що ти любиш то
саме тому ми їх і навчаємо і щоб вони
люблять говорити буду багато хочу Одне
тільки також похвалитися що на
сьогоднішній день певна кількість
переселенців повернулася на свої місця
свої домівки і нам відрадно чути
Оскільки ми з ним підтримуємо зв'язок що
вони знайшли себе вдома і вони працюють
по тим навичкам які вони у нас отримали
сподіваємося що цей їм станем в нагоді і
на подальшу продуктивність зрозуміло що
ми будемо продовжувати роботу в рамках
освітнього хабу бо потре єдиного
робітничих кадрах вона є була і буде ще
зростати Бо нам потрібно з вами всім
відновити нашу Україну Ну ви говорите
буду багато але двох хвилинний
відеоролик якщо можна для демонстрації
навіть півтори хвилини мені потрібні
Мені потрібно здійснити невеличку
зараз секундочку я теж поширю екранчик з
нашим
відеороликом так
Так перепрошую Я теж вчусь у мене
сьогодні
прем'єра з тим щоб навчитися правильно
відображати відео в Зумі так от тепер
Сподіваюся що все буде так як треба
власне поїхали
[музика]
Ні не все так добре як здається я ще раз
спробую в цьому відеоролику ви просто
коротенькі такі огляд як саме
відбувались навчання таким загальним
процесом
що воно дійсно було а не вигаданою
детальну інформацію можна в онлайн
екскурсію
[музика]
[оплески]
навчати актуальним навичкам і професіям
21 століття як місцевих мешканців так і
внутрішньо переміщених осіб які втратили
роботу або просто бажають опанувати нові
фахи за три місяці роботи уже випустили
понад три сотні студентів різних
спеціальностей зараз хаб продовжує
активно працювати в межах області і дав
поштовх для відкриття подібних центрів
інших регіонах та навіть за
так колеги я завершую показ нашого
відеороліка пані Світлана обіцяла
сказати де можна отримати актуальну
інформацію прошу
створений сайт Департаменту освіти науки
молоді та спорту Хмельницької Обласної
Державної адміністрації там є окрема
вкладка освітній хак Хмельниччини де
розповсюджені всі перелік послуг як
зареєструватися як знайти яку можливість
можна отримати і також
онлайн-екскурсія про освітній хаб є на
сайті
інституту держав інституту модернізації
змісту освіти навіть подбувати на
онлайн-екскурсії Дякуємо координаторам
освітнього хабу який нас до цього
долучили Ну і все буде Петро
однозначно без варіантів Шановні колеги
А ми передаємо естафету в наступному
регіону і я до слова запрошую львівщину
пане Івана пикоса начальника відділу
інновацій дистанційного навчання
координації діяльності закладів вищої
освіти і науки професійної освіти
Львівської обласної військової
адміністрації Іване вам слово прошу
Доброго дня шановні колеги Доброго дня
Ірина Володимирівна і локація головна
Вінниччини дуже жаль що не вдалося певно
собі йти причин до вас потрапити Але я
думаю що після того ролику Хмельниччини
Ми спочатку поїдемо в хмельниччину потім
вінниччину і так дальше по всій регіонах
нашої чудової країни
Шановні колеги я дуже коротко так
постараюся побачити що в нас часу Open
вже
про такі сучасні практики навчання в
закладах профтеосвіти Львівщини але перш
ніж то коротко Перепрошую коротко
розкажу про систему про всеосвітиліющій
нас є 49 закладів станом на перше січня
22-го року навчається
20278 здобувчої освіти регіональне
замовлення минулоріч
9500 відповідно бачите відсоток
виконання цьогоріч ми бачимо цифру
9500 і в нас відповідно вже є в
наступному слайді показує який нажив
відсоток виконання в станом на зараз
Тобто ми бачимо тенденцію останніх
декількох років до збільшення що
звичайно нас дуже тішить
власне про професії які ми десь частково
трансформуємо і чи впроваджуємо проект
спільно
ініціаційний департаментом Львівський it
кластер і вище професійне що номер 29
міста Львова ви знаєте така професія для
більшості точно не є нова Але тим не
менш Ми її модернізували в частині і
навчальних планів і
безпосередньо самого підходу тобто
умовно кажучи ми старі кабінети
облаштували за підтримки донорів і
партнерів сучасним обладнанням наш
навчально-методичний центр спільно з
закладом
оновив навчальну програму відповідно
навчальний план запустили з минулого
року по по нових вимогах ринку праці
власне it-кластер він десь генерує ту те
середовище айтішників Львівщини А в нас
досить таки гідно представлено близько
4000 вакансій щороку з'являється на
ринку Львівщини і відповідно ці
випускники які вже закінчать навчальний
заклад по цій програмі матимуть
можливість безпосередньо взаємодіяти за
ті кластером і працелаштовуватися в ті
формуваннях на ринку праці
Ну професія оператор Дрон То напевно ще
зарано говорити про професію Але тим не
менше пані Наталія вже згадувала Ми теж
є учасниками і Дніпропетровщини якщо не
помиляюся
того того проекту Тобто ми фактично десь
спільно вийшли з ідеєю про попровадження
цієї професії ну Наразі це йде мова
більше про курси ми розробили вже
спільну програму Наш
навчально-методичний центр
навчально-методичний центр ну тобто така
група з Дніпра ми створили таку робочу
групу Дякуємо пані Валентині смальць
організації про ООН тому що спільно
взаємодіями власних за підтримки
цієї організації ми реалізовуємо то
проектна закуплено 4 дрони загальну суму
десь близько 250 тисяч у нашій також
проплатили Організація навчання наших
майстрів в Києві вони вже завершили це
навчання і готові до навчання з
подальшому у і
короткострокових курсів які ми плануємо
запустити 21 вересня а саму програму під
скажемо імплантувати в наші напрямки
професії які там зокрема в сільському
господарстві в будівництві в Лісовому
господарстві і так дальше власне це є
також ми
запустили таку професію минулоріч
електромонтер охорони пожежної
сигналізації Напевно вона теж не є нова
така але в регіонах представлена але в
нас вона не була представлена і
відповідно коли мені впровадили нас про
ліцензував наш заклад ви бачите який і
вона зразу пішов досить активний набір з
30 при ліцензованих 29 зразу у нас був
набір цього року теж вже маємо повне
виконання по цій професії
Окрім цього про ліцензували професію
електромонтер з ремонту обслуговування
сонячного електростаткування ви бачите в
нас є Ну такий заклад Червоноградський
професійний будівельний ліцей власне це
такий регіон шахт і ми розуміємо що тема
шахти вона відходить в минуле тобто Ця
історія по-любому буде завершена рано чи
пізно і ми розуміємо що нам треба
впроваджувати професії які носять
альтернативну альтернативний характер
тобто це якась альтернативна енергетика
в сонячні панелі вітровій станції і так
дальше і теж є вже великий набір ще 30
осіб не має звичайно але вже доходимо до
тої цифри і ми крім того взяли участь в
проекті від партнерів з gcz і маємо
надію що він створимо хороший там
навчально-практичний центр власне по цій
професії
формат освітньої академії хто слідкує за
десь Facebook сторінками нашими ми його
впровадили десь два роки тому це власне
такий майданчик для обміну досвіду і
думками наших керівників заступників
директорів з виробничої частини зокрема
більше акцент на них робимо власне де
Вони діляться так само як ми сьогодні з
вами так само Вони збираються і діляться
практиками тому що на жаль наша мережа
49 закладів трошки ще завелика і деякі
керівники направду не мали між собою
навіть контакту коли ми починали
впроваджувати цей захід але потім знаєте
оця взаємодія пішла і сьогодні всі між
собою активно взаємодіють спілкуються в
кого сильніша база проводять різні там
тренінги і так дальше тобто фактично
пішов процес обміну і взаємодії
короткострокові курси власне для
внутрішньо переміщення осіб як згадували
колеги вже з Хмельниччини в рамках
освітнього хабу в нас освітній хаб
процесів створення Ми думаємо що він
буде реалізований цей проект Але ми
почали зі співпраці з
програмою ООН відновлення до миру за
підтримки європейського фінансової
підтримки Європейського Союзу і власне
ми от станом там з третього квітня
ми стартували спочатку квітня у нас
пройшло навчання близько 300 осіб з
числа внутрішнього переміщених
професії ви бачите перелік досить різний
і такий Широкий і
обов'язковою мовою власне тих курсів це
є працевлаштування і Ми ретельно
підходимо буквально вчора в нас
відкривалися екскурсії з кухаря сушиста
де власне прийшла велика мережа така в
нас є яка представлена там музика Ще 5
торго розважальних центрах в них порядка
десятки ресторанів і вони дійсно прийшли
і мотивовано Коуч від них представник
відділу hrу сказав найбільші переваги і
готовність приймати випускників з курсів
на працевлаштування тому справді оці
курси як на мене дуже класна штука
профте у світі і нам потрібно її
розвивати
незалежно від того там для внутрішнього
переміщення осіб А взагалі впроваджувати
і розвивати ту мережу курсів підготовки
тому що на жаль зараз з одного боку
центри зайнятості ми проти них нічого
немає Як звісно але вони не мають далеко
тої бази але проводять курси підготовки
навчально-практичні центри це стосується
всіх напевно в Україні це дуже крута
крутий проект Від міністерства освіти за
що дякуємо всім що впроваджується цей
проект на жаль через війну він десь
скажем призупинив частково надіємося
призупинив та свою діяльність Але тим не
менш наша мережа
навчально-політичних центрів завдяки
такому проекту велика 406 їх було
відкрито в 2021 році власне 5 за рахунок
сувенції один за рахунок коштів
партнерів спецфонді тим не менш ми
все-таки в 22-му році незважаючи на
війну ми маємо намір з обласного бюджету
відкрити три навчально-практичні центри
попередньо вже є
погодження Обласної Державної
адміністрації тому згодом про це
розкажемо як буде реалізація
Також
ви пам'ятаєте всі є Наказ Міністерства
про впровадження такого проекту
створення наглядових рад ми підготували
2021 році вона станом на сьогодні є
створено вісім
наглядових град в закладах просто освіти
це не просто люди на цій фотографії як
ви бачите ліворуч це реальні речі коли
ми бачимо взаємодію Власне цей it
зайти кластером проект це є наслідок
створення наглядової ради і таких
проектів в нас вже є декілька де ми
бачимо навіть таких скажімо закладах
профтеосвіти де вдавалося би ну там
населених пунктах сільських населених
пунктів де відбувалося не так багато є
підприємців і бізнесу Але відгукуються
чи то фермерське господарство чи якісь
маленькі пекарні кондитерські психі і
так дальше І вони хочуть йти профтеху
світу приходять і взаємодіють
допомагають беруть дітей на практику
беруть на навчання Ну скажімо
матеріально бувають випадки долучаються
до того щоб осучаснити навчальний заклад
навчальний господарства це теж напевно
багато регіонів представлені з
навчальними господарствами Ми відновили
цю роботу 21-му році оскільки вони були
ніби створені але формально А ми хочемо
щоб вони реально діяли тому станом на
зараз у нас є 8 навчальних господарств
де ми активізували Звичайно так як і
всіх є проблеми з оформленням земель ми
працюємо над тим і хочемо відновити цю
роботу найактивніше в нас поки що
получається в червонянському вищому
професійному училищі до власне був
створений величезний центр навчання
практичний центр сільськогосподарського
спрямування за що дякуємо ще раз кажу
Міністерство освіти і власне Там ми
бачимо вже
надходження незважаючи навіть на
військові дії тобто заклади засівають
працюють створюють різного роду
господарства різного спрямування і тим
самим наповнюють свій спецфорс
з такого цікавого скажемо ми не
опускаємо також
підприємництво і якісь взагалі
інноваційні підходи винахідницьку тому
що Ну як на мене наші діти багато вміють
робити руками але вони не завжди знають
як умовно кажучи зареєструвати собі там
почати свою справу зареєструвати фопа
створити кооператив кластер не знаю там
ТзОВ і так дальше щоб ну не просто
працювати на когось але ще розумієте
організувати власне оці навички по
фінансовій грамотності по можливості
розвитку свого приватного бізнесу і так
дальше тому в нас є стартап школа і ми
власне співпрацюємо з ними в тому
напрямку щоб розвивати підприємництво
серед учнів про втехусвіти і нас вже два
роки діють такі проекти де ми потім
Запрошуємо журі серед журі є навіть
потенційні інвестори і спонсори цікавих
скажем інноваційних підходів і думок
учнів А в нас таке Слава богу є і
впевнений що в кожному регіоні вони є
конкурси фахової майстерності це не є
щось нове Напевно ви їх всіх проводите
окрім конкурсів ми Стараємося оці власне
практичні навички закріплювати на
конкурсах щорічних конкурсах пахової
майстерності з різних професій це дуже
Ну я дуже люблю ті заходи як на мене це
дуже класно і розвиває як і учнів і
потенційно можна побачити реально замір
знань закладів практичних знань і
навиків не теоретичних і в принципі воно
як на мене рекомендую що воно потрібно
робити незважаючи ні на що
ну окрім того ми знаємо в нас був виклик
з ковітом зараз війна нас дистанційне
навчання частково теж є залишається
пріоритетом ми
залучили невелику суму коштів з
обласного бюджету Але тим не менш на 34
заклади було учасниками платформи онлайн
навчання платформа Motul вони освоювали
І власне щоб їм було простіше потім
провести онлайн урок і так дальше
в принципі на цьому все єдине що хочу ще
сказати дійсно як багато колег говорили
про
допомогу
благодійну допомогу скажемо про
волонтерський проект дійсно знаєте в час
війни наші не знає як вас на місцях але
в нас на місцях зрозумілих і органи
місцевого самоврядування зрозуміло
важливість профте освіти що може скажемо
що тішить дуже тішить нас тому що ну не
тільки тому що от вони побачили
можливість ВПО помістити в наших
гуртожитках а тому що ми там можемо
зварити і їсти і протитанкові їжаки І
знаєте ми пошили 15 тисяч аптечок коли
всі ну в шоці були ви кажете як приватне
підприємство велике зробили І знаєте
багато речей просто освіта може і
справді то гасло що десь там ви
запустили ту про Міністерство освіти
запустило ту промоцію дійсно Все робимо
завдяки нам це відповідає дійсності і
переконаний що штормітні органи
місцевого самоврядування Ми дуже сильно
в кожен раз показуємо пальцем органом
місцевого самоврядування особливо
громадам оскільки ПДФО ми їм сплачуємо і
друзі давайте долучайтеся і покращити ті
заклади і тоді вони будуть справді
успішними Дякую всім радий бачити Я
думаю що просто освіта і наша Україна
обов'язково разом Ми переможемо всіх
Дякую вам дякую доро
гі друзі надзвичайно вдячність всім
представникам західних регіонів України
ми знаємо як ви відгукнулися і зараз
продовжуєте неймовірно просто працю
волонтерську на підтримку внутрішнього
переміщених осіб на підтримку Збройних
Сил України Це дійсно
вартує слід подяки і
низького клону ми говорили вже про зміст
Ми поговорили трошки про мережу А зараз
Інше питання без якого ніяк і рухатися
не можна це професійний розвиток
викладача це вдосконалення викладача це
програми підвищення кваліфікації я і
задоволенням надаю слово пані Вікторії
Сидоренко директору Білоцерківського
інституту неперервної професійної освіти
університету менеджменту освіти
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України доктор педагогічних наук
професор Пані Вікторія прошу
Доброго дня Ми з України Так традиційно
ми розпочинаємо вже всі місяці будь-який
захід і будь-яку зустріч із нашими
замовниками і з нашими студентами і з
ключовими стейкхолдером
і
сьогоднішній захист сьогоднішня зустріч
не буде я думаю винятком Доброго дня Ми
з України Шановні колеги і ті
організатори які
переповнюють думки переповнюють емоції я
спробую трошечки пізніше ними поділитися
передусім
завжди Серпень це
споконвічно для українців це місяць
збору врожаю це місяць жнив а
сьогоднішня Серпнева така конференція це
не тільки
взагалі узагальнення того що зроблено це
звичайно намічення певних подальших
перспектив і найближчих перспектив
недаремно класика Ліни Василівни
Костенко І кожен фініш - це по суті
старт хочеться побажати від імені родини
Білоцерківського інституту звичайно
неперервною професійної освіти Я знаю що
підключені спостерігають бо в групах
наших студентство перегукується
обмінюється
емоціями певними і Для нас це приємно
оскільки не тільки науково-педагогічні і
педагогічні працівники наші роботодавці
ключові стрільбходери беруть сьогодні
участь але й наше студентство тому я
хочу сьогодні привітати всіх учасників
сьогоднішньої серпневої конференції
звичайно побажати Мирного вдалого
успішного старту і найголовніше що був
мир Шановні колеги звичайно питання
професійного розвитку на сьогодні в
період її воєнного стану набуває зовсім
інших акцентів і саме цитатою
сьогоднішнього дня коли ми говоримо про
реформи коли говоримо про
перетрансформацію про професійне пере
інакшення завжди пригадую видатного
Альберта Ейнштейна жодна проблема не
вирішується на рівні на якому вона
виникає з якими проблемами стикаємось ми
наш інститут наші замовники під час
підвищення кваліфікації
перенавчання педагогічних працівників і
керівного складу передусім як завжди ми
говоримо що безперервний професійний
розвиток На сьогодні це відповідь на
нестабільність у сфері зайнятості і
професії це завжди було до війни чотири
сфери на які ми звертали увагу це
особистісний соціальний професійний і
культурний розвиток фахівця звичайно
здатність і можливість
змінюватись адаптуватися в певних умовах
в умовах змін
економічних соціальних професійних Ну і
звичайно якщо говорити про закон України
про освіту стаття 18 освіта дорослих
безперервний професійний розвиток це
безперервний процес навчання
вдосконалення професійних
компетентностей який триває впродовж
життя людини не даремно уміння вчитися і
перенавчатися це так топова навичка яка
Прогнозується експертами на ринку праці
до 2030 року
якщо ми говоримо про певні перетворення
професійні перетворення це завжди
відповіді на три питання і три стани
яких зараз перебуває кожен педагогічний
працівник і керівник чому І як І що Що
наприклад чекає і Якщо раніше ми
звертали увагу на діяльність ні
перетворення в структурі професіонала
особистості Тобто це і роз питання семи
системи професійних умінь і навичок і
компетентна активність сучасного фахівця
його включеність у процес прийняття
рішень і його професійна ініціатива то
під час воєнного стану ці акценти
видозмінюються я не даремно сьогодні
дібрала улюблену картинку чому улюблену
вона є стимулом для певної модернізації
і Для певних трансформацій які ми
проводимо в нашому інституті передусім
ці освітні тренди які характеризують не
тільки сучасний ринок праці але й
суспільство зокрема і крім зміни
структури зайнятості і цифровізації
нового обладнання і тих нових професій
які нас чекають після війни і звичайно
наша дистанційна робота дистанційне
навчання хотіла б звернути увагу ще на
один дуже важливий аспект чому саме ми
пере Іна створити свою роботу в період
війни і сподіваємось післявоєнний період
за даними організації економічної
співпраці і розвитку
обсяглобального трудового ресурсу
складає на сьогодні три з половиною
мільярди осіб рівень компетенції майже
кожного 3-го працівника або надмірний
або недостатньо тобто приблизно 1,2 млрд
осіб усьому світі займають посаду які не
відповідають практичним навичкам або
тому рівні кваліфікації яке здобув той
чи інший працівник тому на сьогодні
важливого значення особливо в системі
післядипломної професійної освіти
набуває аспект компетенізацію освіти
тобто орієнтації на вихід аутбуд на
результат у вигляді розвинутих ключових
фахових міжпредметних інтегративних
компетентностей які допомагають
сучасному фахівцеві навчатися впродовж
життя
Шановні колеги Хочу звернути вашу увагу
що звичайно сьогодні роботодавці як
ніколи роблять ставку на крос
функціональність персоналу на володіння
певними вміннями і навичками які
дозволяють успішно і кваліфіковану
сучасному робітникові виконувати свої
професійні завдання і функції тобто наше
завдання саме післядипломної професійної
освіти проводити компетенції працівників
у відповідність до Запитів роботодавців
ключових стріль-холдерів враховуючи не
тільки ринок праці який постійно
оновлюється постійно певні вимоги
постійно певні потреби наприклад у тих
професіях які зараз
є актуальними А ще один дуже важливий
момент ми працюємо завжди говорять про
талановитість і презунцію талановитості
здобувача освіти а в нашому закладі ми
говоримо про презумнію талановипусті
кожного педагогічного працівника адже ми
працюємо і з дорослими учнями які не
тільки мають свій життєвий
компетентнісний досвід який можуть які
можуть одночасно і навчатися і працювати
Ну і звичайно які потребують того
спектру навичок які вони отримали
застосувати Практично на практиці А це
передбачає є в свою чергу модернізації і
змісту і форм і удосконалення тих
сучасних моделей підвищення кваліфікації
педагогів закладів
професійно-професійного технічної освіти
які на сьогодні є на ринку освітніх
послуг
мені хочеться це передусім зазначити і
звернути увагу саме керів не тільки
педагогічних працівників а саме
керівників Справа в тому що ми з вами
перебуваємо в надзвичайному такому
середовищі надзвичайному становищі Я
сьогодні чому говорю надзвичайно тому що
в нас Підкова пандемія нас спіткала і
соціальна дистанційність звичайно і
воєнний стан і залежно від того як ми
реагуємо на всі ці вимоги на всі ці
виклики і потреби два різні є стани і я
переконана у те що я сьогодні
спостерігала це саме стан акомодації
станусиміляції коли ми вбудовуємось в
певну нову ситуацію без змін приймаємо
осмислюємо певний досвід а от стан
акомодації коли до того що ми бачимо ми
змінюємо наші дії ми переносимо щось
своє ми надаємо нові моделі мислення
оцінки ділимося власним досвідом
ділимось власною практикою і не
забуваємо ще про дуже важливий момент і
знову-таки сьогоднішньої серпневої
студії я зрозуміла чому
говорять ніби друге натхнення ніби друге
повітря Таке враження що хочеться може
це створити і так далі звертаю вашу
увагу на криву змін я недаремно будую
свою доповідь саме за моделлю
компетентнісного підходу відзнаннєвої
парадигми до умінь і навичок результатів
так от хочеться сказати що ті стани які
ми пережили і переживаємо саме в тих
умовах пандемії в умовах дистанційного
навчання і В умовах воєнного стану
керував змін Джона Фішера 99-го року яка
актуальна і для нас і я думаю кожен із
цих станів ви для себе зараз осмислити
від гніву передчуття розчарування шоку
емоційного прийняття до певної
впевненості Ну і до певної стабільності
і Якщо говорити про всі ці зміни які і
відбуваються і які спонукають нас
видозмінюватись звичайно на сьогодні
зараз Шановні колеги звичайно на
сьогодні найбільшого значення для нас
набуває саме в системі післядипломної
освіти Саме ці уміння і навички з якими
вийде після підвищення кваліфікації
після набуття проходження певних курсів
наш педагогічний працівник я звернув
увагу на два важливих аспекти які ми
враховуємо в нашій роботі Ну передусім
Якщо говорити про європейський словник
навичок і компетентностей а там де ми
знаходимо інформацію про кожну професію
11 мовами завдання обов'язки необхідні
певні навички необхідні уміння тощо далі
хотіла б звернути увагу ще на один
ресурс важливий який ми також
використовуємо британська платформа для
навчання з кіосхеонід там де
задокументовано описано саме тих 8
навичок які потрібні для освіти дорослих
для впевненого критичного вдумливого
виконання своїх професійних обов'язків
але ми провели саме в період воєнного
стану власне дослідження тому що
розуміємо що підвищення кваліфікації я
хочу сказати саме про нашу інститут у
нас не було жодного дня простою Можливо
тому що заклад переживає це другий раз
Можливо тому що найбільша сила такої
мобілізаційної активності але жодного
дня
щоб не було проведено певне певного
освітнього процесу простої у нас не було
так от на що ми звернули увагу
саме в період воєнного стану тобто з
лютого або і по червень місяць Ми
провели онлайн-опитування саме про цін
важливі навички які потрібні в
професійній діяльності під час саме
вільний тобто що зараз необхідно Якщо
раніше ми проводили таке опитування і у
нас результати цієї вони розглядались на
радість якості освіти навчання раді то
що на сьогодні є важливим І що на
сьогодні є
необхідним саме для педагогічних
працівників Зверніть будь ласка увагу що
акценти зовсім змінилися передусім ми
пропонували зробити градацію цих навичок
тобто від найважливіших на сьогодні до
найменш затребуваних і ви бачите що на
перші місця це не тільки орієнтація на
надання послуг да Що робити здобувачами
як вивозити як забезпечити освітнє
середовище безпечне стресостійкість
гнучкість і дуже багато наших замовників
Ви бачили що там 1800 респондентів які
взяли можливість в цьому опитуванні
адаптивність тобто здатність
орієнтуватися не тільки несподіваних
ситуаціях але приймати певні рішення це
і комунікація звичайно не поступаються і
цифрові навички цей критичне мислення
саморегуляція і відповідно до цього
опитування також до певних Запитів наших
замовників ми змінили деякі акценти які
до цього для нас були важливими і
актуальними саме в період воєнного стану
на базі бенфо за різними формами і
моделями навчання я хочу сказати що у
нас поширена ще модель навчання на
виробництві пройшли курси підвищення
кваліфікації 3 032 педагоги із них за
державним замовленням 1067 взагалі за
рік проходить за державним замовленням
педагоги професійно-професійного
технічної освіти 2000 а підвищення
кваліфікації у нас завжди сягає більше
чотирьох з половиною тисяч освітян тому
саме в період воєнного стану нас
покладались мабуть найбільше завдання це
і мобілізація це і
оптимізація і згуртованість тих хто
довірив нам освіту одне із найголовніших
тих навичок які на сьогодні вимагаються
потребуються ми зазвичай підвищуємо
кваліфікацію трьох категорій слухачів це
викладачі
професійно-теоритичної підготовки це
майстри виробничого навчання і старші
майстри Якщо говорити про
Якщо говорити про тонувацію до якої ми
дійшли звичайно на сьогодні ми
підвищуємо кваліфікацію за
передусім і працюємо над ефективністю і
якістю системи безперервної професійної
освіти за допомогою впровадження
компетентнісну орієнтованих моделей
підвищення кваліфікації у нас до десятки
саме тих шкіл які забезпечують набуття
конкретних навичок для ефективної
взаємодії і для виконання своїх
професійних обов'язків це школа
передового педагогічного досвіду це є
школа педагогічного коучингу це школа
лідерів професійної освіти студія
корпоративного тимбілдингу онлайн студія
цифрових технологій Якщо говорити про ту
новацію яку принесли саме
компетентнісну орієнтовані моделі
підвищення кваліфікації все отримання
результатів навчання у формі передусім
фахових компетентностей це набуття
навичок Soft і Hard Skills це формування
певних цінностей і поведінкових
індикаторів це заповнення прогалень між
потребами і пропозицією це створення
того людиноцентрованого навчання де
надається перевага суб'єктні активності
саме дорослого учня який самостійно може
вибирати терміни зміст навчання форму
умови здійснювати ціле покладання і
корекцію зовсім нових умовах і ще про
одну новацію на яку б я хотіла звернути
увагу у нас вона запроваджена була в
червні місяці це короткотермінові
тематичні курси підвищення кваліфікації
передусім це 6 напрямів від інклюзії
цифрової компетентності
новітніх технологій навчання і виховання
педагогічного менеджменту психології
професійної діяльності Ну і звичайно
якщо говорити про ще один важливий
аспект охорона праці і безпека
життєдіяльності Якщо говорити про
коротку строкові тематичні курси
підвищення кваліфікації передусім це
набуття конкретних фахових
компетентностей які відповідають
суспільним особистісним потребам
викликам ринку праці які допомагають
долати розрив між тим дизбалансом Яким є
на ринку праці і потребами Ну і звичайно
які стимулюють здобувачів освіти
працюючого і не зайнятого населення саме
розвиватися і саме вдосконалюватись
впродовж життя набувати нові
кваліфікації набувати нові професії ще
про одну інновацію хотіла сказати з
лютого місяця у нас відбувалася три дні
поспіль щотижня два заходи передусім це
онлайн-марафон сила України у кожного з
нас і і повторюються з лютого місяця і
по червень включно і відкриті публічні
лекції для педагогів батьків дітей
навколо саме цих двох заходів а це
вівторок середа і п'ятниця брали участь
не тільки волонтери науково-педагогічні
працівники педагогічні працівники
дуже багато було б запитань і дуже
багато Саме проведена майстер-класів для
дітей і батьків які постраждали під час
воєнних дій окрім того якщо говорити ще
про одну новацію за допомогою якої Нам
вдалося реалізувати ті новації і ці
плани які ми маємо у нас в інституті
створена єдина цифрова екосистема
освітня екосистема це дві потужні
ліцензійні платформи це віртуальна школа
педагогічного коучингу це консалтинговий
центр
методична скарбничка які допомагають
нашим педагогічним працівникам
здійснювати професійний розвиток і
професійних досконалення впродовж вже
між курсового періоду
крім того Зараз акцент робиться не
тільки на цифрових навчально-методичних
комплексах вони у нас є на сайті в нашій
електронній бібліотеці цифрові
бібліотеці які стосуються не тільки
набуття певних навичок певних
компетентностей але і друга платформа
про яку я говорю профосвіта яка включає
і наших роботодавців і ключових
стрількодерів є рубрики для
самовдосконалення і саме розвитку
Шановні колеги я завершую виступ розумію
що трошечки вичерпало час але хочу знову
таки
[музика]
впродовж саме воєнного стану в нашому
інституті Я думаю в Україні саме ця
фраза і це гасло не було особливого
значення от тому в лихо годину милих її
вперті бо для вільної людини рабство
більш смерті Шановні колеги бажаю вам
миру
злагоди згуртованості і звичайно
сподіваюсь що все буде Україна це буде
Петро
дякую пані Вікторію за такий змістовний
дійсно доповідь і можливості для наших
педагогів розвиватися удосконалюватися
це на сьогодні і дуже важливо Шановні
колеги ми перебираємо останнім ми
затягуємося з нашими виступами але всі
спікери сьогодні мали змогу змогу
презентувати наші результати У мене є
результат
звернень від наших колег які працюють з
нами ті вже більше 2 години онлайн є
питання коли повернуть доплати за
престижність кабінети і таке інше
шановні друзі не забуваємо що в нас іде
війна ми розуміємо все і сподіваємося
якщо тільки війна закінчиться всі
доплати будуть повернено на сьогодні Є
відповідне без розпорядження Кабінету
Міністрів ніяких стимулюючих надбавок на
жаль не виплачуються є питання стосовно
мобілізації викладачів
на них треба дати більш розгорнуту
відповідь Ані процеси З долученням наших
представників з відділом мобілізації є
питання стосовно
акредитації кваліфікаційних центрів Я
думаю що зважаючи на такий запит на
проведемо окремо зустріч онлайн з
презентуємо все що потрібно навіщо які
умови і найбільша кількість питань яка
до нас надійшла від маріупольського
професійного ліцею сфери послуг і
торгівлі так дійсно ви пам'ятаєте Я в
своєму виступі говорила що організація
роботи закладів на тимчасово окупованих
територіях це на сьогодні одна з
найбільших проблем і з найбільших питань
які потребують врегулювання Шановні
колеги з маріупольського ліцею нам треба
з вами окремо мати зустріч відповідно з
вашими обласними органами управління
освітою проговорити
ті проблеми які на сьогодні існують з
ліцеєм від себе гарантую ми не будемо
зараз витрачати час на обговорення таких
не зовсім дотичних тем нашої
сьогоднішньої зустрічі ми обов'язково
зробимо окремий файл з усіма вашими
питаннями дамо на них розлоги відповіді
і залученням фахівців і в цю рубрику де
буде наша секція професійно-технічної
освіти Ми їх зафіксуємо до
маріупольського ліцею обіцяємо вам
організувати окрему зустріч з
департаментом освіти Донецької обласної
військової адміністрації були відповідні
оголошення що не працює телефон шановні
друзі телефон Міністерства освіти і
науки працює мій телефон ну 44
8705 будь ласка звертайтеся кожного дня
Якщо Як сьогодні не відряджені на роботі
спробую допомогти всім чим зможу дорогі
друзі Ми Щиро дякуємо всіх хто сьогодні
долучився до нашої дискусії до нашого
спілкування
шалено Дякую нашим спікерам нашим
колегам які багато поділилися
інформацією розказали про все і
дякую за увагу з боку наших слухачів з
наших колег освітян так залишилось
зовсім трошки менше двох тижнів до
початку нового навчального року а
подекуди Ми вже його почали ви знаєте в
нас були такі пропозиції окремі заклади
розпочали роботу з 15 серпня цей рік
Буде непростий нам здавався що ковід для
нас великий виклик Як виявилося ковід
таке собі але ми мусимо йти далі
дивитися в майбутнє з оптимізмом з Вірою
тільки у перемогу З божою підтримкою Я
впевнена що нам все вдасться Що ми
подолаємо що профосвіта стане
найпопулярнішою ланкою освіти в Україні
а далі ми будемо наш досвід поширювати в
Європі і інші міжнародний партнерам Я
вас всіх обіймаю нехай дистанційно бажаю
тільки розвитку міцного здоров'я віри
сили І дійсно прекрасного майбутнього в
нашій державі до нових зустрічей шановні
друзі е-е знову ж таки повторюсь вся
інформація буде розміщення на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки у розділі
серпневої конференції
Слава Україні
Героям слава
до побачення дякую